What we're looking for in this equation is the maximum value that p can have and
the corresponding c value or the c value at which that p value occurs. Well
remember what this curve looks like overall. It was a problem that opens
downward. That means that the maximum point here is just the. The vertex. So
that's exactly what we want to find. The C value and P value that we're looking
for are just the coordinates of our vertex. Let's get this in vertex form, then.
So we need to go through out typical process of completing the square to get
this forumla in vertex form. Note that it actually skipped one step. That I
included in the past. When I subtract this constant from both sides of the
equation, I know that I'm doing that in order to get the right side to equal our
perfect square. In the past I've written out what this entire polynomial is
multiplied out, and then factored it as a step after that, but we don't really
need to do that. The reason is that I already know the factored form of the
polynomial that we're creating by adding this before I even add on the constant
term. The number that I'm adding to c, this negative 46 in this case, is just
the coefficient of the c to the first term divided by 2. Since that's the thing
that we're squaring in order to come up with what we're adding the end to make
this a perfect square. So going through all these steps gives us our final
equation of p minus 290,000 equals negative 200 times the quantity c minus 46
squared. From here we can read straight off that our vertex must be at 46,
290,000. So what does this tell us? Well it tells us exactly the information
that we were looking for. Grant will earn a maximum possible profit of $290,000
per month if he makes his wiper sets cost $46 each.